It's easier to think about it like
breeds of dogs. So, you hear a lot of dogs
that are called things like retrievers
like "Labrador Retrievers", "Golden
Retrievers" they're all in like the same
"family", but you can kind of tell the
difference between them when you look at them and what they do. So, scientists have
a way of telling them apart.
So, all of COVID-19 is one specific type
Coronavirus. It's specifically like one
breed of dog, say: "a Labrador", and for us how
we tell this is we can look at the
genetic material inside of it, what
essentially the virus is trying to
replicate and pass on and make more of and we can
get the sequence of it. Essentially like
reading the book that's inside of it, and
we know alright if it says you know
these certain things then it's this type
of virus. So, by getting that information
that's actually how we run tests to see
if people are sick with the flu or with
this virus is by looking at the
instruction in the virus and you read
it and say, "okay it's this type of virus".
And, the reason why—to answer the part
about "bats", there's something also that we
can do with that information, because not
every species of animal reads that
genetic information the same way, we can
look at features of it and they're sort
of like little bookmarks in the virus
that show where it came from and so we
look for those bookmarks to tell whether—like "what" has influenced where it's
come from. Because, the virus uses the same bookmarks that its hosts does.
So a virus for bats will have all of
the bat "bookmarks", and a virus for dogs
or for people will have all of the dog or person bookmarks.
And, it takes a while for those to go
away so since this is new to us it
doesn't have all of the human stuff yet so we can still read all those little old bat
bookmarks and say, "okay that's what
this is, that's where this came from".